Ahsoka escaped with Rex's help who'd
removed his inhibitor chip that
controlled his mind they faked their
deaths and buried their fallen comrades
on a moon after Order 66 Ahsoka went
into hiding and adopted the code name
fulcrum she became an informant and
operative for bail organa's Rebel
Network she helped various Rebel cells
across the Galaxy such as Harrison
doula's ghost crew on lothal she also
encountered Darth Vader who was her
former Master Anakin ahsoka's original
lightsabers had green blades but they
were later changed to Blue by Anakin as
a gift before the siege of Mandalore she
tracked down an imperial Inquisitor
fought him and managed to take his
red-bladed lightsabers she used the
force to purify the kyber crystals
inside the hilts this process turned the
blades white reflecting Ahsoka status as
neither a Jedi or a Sith but as
something else in the year 9 ABY Ahsoka
arrived on corvus where she met din
jarin a Mandalorian Bounty Hunter who is
looking for a Jedi to help train grogu
Ahsoka agreed to help Den in exchange
for information on the location of Grand
Admiral thrawn a former Imperial officer
who had kidnapped Ezra and disappeared
into the unknown regions